who's the greatest chess player of all
time
the question of who the greatest chess
player of all time is a matter of debate
and subjective opinion however many
consider Gary Kasparov to be the
greatest chess player of all time due to
his numerous accomplishments and
contributions to the game Kasparov was
the world chess champion from 1985 to
2000 and during that time he dominated
the Chess World with his incredible
skill and strategic Acumen he also set
numerous records such as being the
youngest ever Undisputed World chess
champion at the age of 22. kasparov's
Legacy extends Beyond just his playing
career he was a prolific writer and
commentator on the game and he has
contributed greatly to the study and
development of Chess Theory his famous
matches against the IBM computer deep
blue also helped to popularize the game
of chess and bring it to a wire audience
while there are certainly other players
who could be considered for the title of
greatest chess player of all time
Casper's achievements and contributions
make him a strong candidate for the
title